house of the dragon teaser trailer is
out leaving many of you excited for
what's to come but also leaving some of
you confused about certain things but do
not worry
this is why we decided to make an
explanation video explaining everything
and more bringing some things to your
attention which you may have missed
first things first let's explain what
house of the dragon is about it's about
a targaryen civil war that saw the end
of many targaryens and most of their
dragons it nearly destroyed their entire
house
the series is based on george r martin's
book fire and blood which covers the
entire targaryen history in westeros the
prequel series house of the dragon finds
the targaryen dynasty at the absolute
apex of its power with around 20 dragons
flying over king's landing and
dragonstone
targaryen's slow fall begins almost 192
years before the events of game of
thrones banking viserys targaryen breaks
with a century of tradition
by naming his daughter rhaenyra heir to
the iron throne but when visery's later
father is a son
the court is shocked that rhaenyra
retains her status as his heir and seeds
of division so friction across the realm
so basically the show starts with king
viserys the first targaryen sitting on
the iron throne with rhaenyra his oldest
child
being kizer instead of his son aegon
much to the displeasure of fagon's
mother queen ellis and hightower the
real trouble starts when king viserys
dies in the end of season 1
leading to a targaryen civil war over
who should be the next king or queen
with half of westeros siding with aegon
and the other half with rhaenyra but
back to the season 1 events covered by
this teaser first you can see daemon
targaryen with a torch walking through
the dragonglass cave of dragonstone with
rami and jovari's music in the
background we then hear daemon targaryen
pronouncing ominous words
god's kings fire and blood
dreams did not make us kings dragons did
referring to aegon to conquer a dream to
conquer the seven kingdoms as well as
about dani's dream to escape valyria as
he speaks you see a succession of quick
shots daemon an older version of
rhaenyra targaryen on driftmark shorn
these two uncle and niece who eventually
become husband and wife are the main
characters in the series
next is aegon to conquer dragon valerian
the black dread skull the dragon
recently died of old age with king
viserys himself being his last rider
this is his resting place
then you see a shot of the hand of the
king it's a road of hightower besides
being handed to king viserys he is also
the father of the king's wife queen
ellison hightower who they later save
with a dagger it's the very same dagger
that arya used to kill the night king
200 years after as you can see alison is
in distress caused by this very same
dagger that was used by rhaenyra's child
against alison's child when prince
aemond targaryen attempted to ride vegar
one of house targaryen's dragons he was
confronted by rhaenyra's children eamonn
broke the nose of five-year-old luke who
eventually took out damon's eye with his
dagger
and here's his mother alison demanding
justice from king viserys
demanding an eye for an eye
this puts king viserys in a hard spot as
a man is his son but lucerus is his
grandson behind alice and you can see
two members of the kingsguard one being
star harold westerling and the other
being sir kristen cole
himself becoming major allison supporter
after falling off with princess rhaenyra
speaking of the king viserys here you
have a shot of him sitting on the iron
throne with a targaryen ring on his
finger
as he holds blackfire one of two of
house targaryen's ancestral valyrian
steel swords if you look closely you'll
notice that he is also equipped with a
valyrian steel dagger the same dagger we
just saw in allison's hand before it
ended up in alison's hand king viserys
gave it to his grandson lucerus as a
gift who then attacked his son with it
back to the sword blackfyre is a sword
wielded by aegon to conquer which was
passed down from king to king
and finally you see it in its full glory
it's got a cross guard fashioned as a
pair of dragon heads with dragon wings
at its pummel you can see a
seven-pointed star a decoration that did
not exist when aegon the conqueror
builded it but was added by king
jaehaerys the symbol of the king being
the defender of the faith
there you can also see young rhaenyra
who is appointed by her father to be his
heir
followed by a shot of older rhaenyra who
is accompanied by daemon targaryen
this time she is not at king's landing
where she used to be when she was
younger
she is now at driftmark the seat of
house valerian
attending the funeral of damon's second
wife both of them are visibly sad as it
was daemon's wife and rhaenyra's good
friend
then you see a fight scene that takes
place earlier in the story between
daemon and kristen cole
giving you the first look at targaryen
armor helmet shield as well as dark's
sister a famous sword of house targaryen
once fielded by aegon the conqueror's
sister visenya the dark sister has the
cross guard fashioned as a pair of
dragon wings with the head being at the
base of the blade
daemon wears the dragon helm
the same one rhaegar wore at the trident
when he fought robert baratheon the
armor is also the same except rehgar had
rubies attached to it his opponent
kristen cole is an exceptionally skilled
warrior himself along with daemon being
the best warriors of this time and
kristen is particularly skilled with his
morning star which you can see here as
well it's the tourney for king viserys
the first accession
where in the final fight sir kristen
cole fights his final opponent prince
daemon targaryen and actually wins by
knocking aside daemon's dark sister with
his morning star
he then gives the victor's laurel to
young princess rhaenyra targaryen
kristen subsequently becomes a favorite
at court and joins the kingsguard next
up is corliss valerian known as the sea
snake a fable the lord of the tides
master of driftmark
and the head of house valerian who comes
from the old valyria
much like targaryens he is one of
rhaenyra supporters and a good friend of
daemon having one child married to
rhaenyra and the other to daemon he
himself is the husband of princess
rainey's targaryen
and here you see a shot of the valerian
family entering the iron throne room
looking rich and powerful as they truly
are on the left is sea snake's nephew
surveyment the older ladies his wife
reign is targaryen known as the queen
that never was
and the other two are his children lane
or elena you can also see more of
valerians in the background
they are arriving here because the sea
snake's son lenore is being married to
the king's daughter rhaenyra and this is
their wedding feast
you can see both targaryen and valerian
flags hanging behind him
with all the important lords and ladies
attending the feast to avoid confusion
rhaenys has silver hair instead of black
which she has in the books
indicating she has a valyrian look and
is a targaryen
while mysteria has black hair instead of
white as she does in the books making it
clear she's not of valyrian descent
she's a dancer from lis who became the
paramour of prince daemon targaryen and
the unofficial mistress of whisperers to
queen rhaenyra targaryen
during the dance of the dragons
then we have another attorney where you
can see all sorts of banners including
house stark and house lannister this is
a great tourney on the 5th anniversary
of king viserys the first and queen
allison's marriage at king's landing the
reason you see tarly banners on the wall
is because sir kristen cole is fighting
a thoroughly in this round it's during
the opening feast on this very same
tourney that queen allison wore a green
gown
while princess rhaenyra dressed in the
red and black of house targaryen note
was taken and thereafter he became the
custom to refer to greens and blacks
when talking of the queen's party and
the party of the princess respectively
prince daemon targaryen returns to
king's landing as king during this
journey from his wars at the stepstones
to serve filthy to his brother king
visery is the first targaryen this
little shot is of sir kristen cole on
horse entirely then you have another
fighting scene
this time between the sea snake's son
lenore and leonard's friend and lover
sir coral cory
which will not go well to say at least
young rainer is then visiting her father
king viserys where you see a new version
of the iron throne it's not exactly all
new as the chair itself remains the same
but it's surrounded by new swords making
it look a little bit closer to what the
iron throne looks in the books in order
to stay true to the look the iron throne
head in game of thrones
but also get a little closer to the look
the iron throne has in the books it's
been decided to add the swords around
the throne thus making it a bit closer
to the books the swords that were once
fielded against egg on the conqueror are
now defending the targaryen kings on the
throne this is where we come to an end
but before we end it i would just like
to reveal to you that the filming of
season 1 is still ongoing and will be
finished next month when it enters
post-production and soon after airs on
hbo all of this and more you will see in
2022 on hbo thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video
please give it a big thumbs up and i
hope to see you in the next one peace
foreign